there was a lot going on at this year's
comic-con among others Marvel announced
a lot of new movies and serious and
previous rumors were confirmed or turned
out to be wrong in the following we have
gathered all relevant information for
you to give you an overview of the phase
four of the MCU the successor of Captain
Marvel which had been released this year
was confirmed
unfortunately Marvel did not reveal much
more information and the release date is
still unknown one of the bigger
surprises was that Marvel announced
another part to blade however not with
Wesley Snipes as in the first three
movies but with the currently very
popular green book actor mashaallah Ali
Ali will also be known to many from the
serious house of cards where he portrays
the tough lobbyist Remy Danton obviously
the new blade part won't have much to do
with that as you now embodies the
superhero with the abilities of a
vampire to protect the population from
exactly those however this news couldn't
get by without outrage either because
many fans of the original movies weren't
happy about the cast of Ally especially
after last year when Snipes showed
himself confident that he will take over
the role of Eric Brooks aka played again
for the Thor fans among you we have also
some news as not only the name of the
fourth-floor movie was revealed but also
some surprises in terms of the cast the
sequel will be named love and thunder
and matching the title hoarse ex-lover
Jane Foster portrayed by Natalie Portman
will return however Jane Foster will not
only look good next to Thor but will
also be the well-known Mighty Thor from
the comics
of course the direction will again be
left to Taika Waititi again and we can
assume that the new part just like its
predecessor will be more on the humorous
than the gloomy side as it has been
known for sometime
Black Widow will be the first face for
film to be released on 1st of May 2020
but what was a bit surprising was the
appearance of the Willam taskmaster in
the new movie with Scarlett Johansson
his main characteristic is that he has
photographic reflexes from birth and can
therefore perfectly copy the movements
of other people just by watching them a
pretty serious opponent as he doesn't
only master close combat as well as
Black Widow he also has the precision of
Hawkeye
more infos and trailers about Black
Widow should be released soon after all
the release is already next year
furthermore at Comic Con Black Panther 2
was confirmed however more information
was withheld from us at the time being
since the work on the second Black
Panther part is still in its first
stages we cannot expect more detailed
information for now the more detailed
explanation was given about the Eternals
which have been part of the Marvel
Comics since the 70s the group consists
of several godlike creatures created by
the Celestials but which look more like
humans however they differ anonymously
in their powers abilities and lifespans
their opponents are the deviants who are
in an endless war with the Eternals and
have not less strong powers the ones
affected are the people who suffer from
the devastating wars in any case cinema
goers can expect an exciting storyline
and an action firework for the eyes the
cinema lounge is scheduled for November
6 2020 another surprises MCU is first
Asian superhero shang-chi Chang she
doesn't have any superpowers but he's
extremely well trained in martial arts
and co and certainly not an easy
opponent how he will fit into the MCU is
still questionable the shooting of Shang
she will start after the shooting of the
Eternals
leading roles will be played by cimoli
us Chang ji and tony leung as the
villain also a second part of Doctor
Strange called Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness will be released
definitely no hidden him that the
multiverse will finally be introduced
just like in the Marvel comics which
brings a lot of new possibilities to the
MCU for example dead characters like
Tony Stark or Black Widow could appear
on the screen again the release date is
7th of May 2021 somewhat disappointed
are the guardians of the galaxy fans for
more than just a confirmation of Kevin
Feige it was unfortunately not enough
space at comic-con many fans are already
waiting impatiently for a release date
sadly James Gunn had to explain on
Twitter that he has to finish the
Suicide Squad before I can start working
on guardians of the galaxy 3 the only
input that has been in the room for
quite some time is that Rocket Raccoon
will play a key role at the moment most
people are speculating on a cinema
released not before 2022
not only movies but also upcoming Disney
Plus series were announced at comic-con
for example the serious la Falcon and
the Winter Soldier with am to the Mackey
and his new Captain America shield will
be released Sebastian Stan will also be
in his role as Winter Soldier and Daniel
Bruhl as villain helmet Sammy
furthermore elizabeth Olsen will get her
own series s Scarlet Witch aka Wanda
Maximoff the series will also be
dedicated to Tony Stark's Android vision
and Tom Hiddleston's character Loki in
addition Jeremy Renner will appear in
his role as Hawkeye in a known series
the long announced serious what if which
is supposed to show many alternative
realities of the Marvel film universe
will also be shown in animated form on
this necklace we hope you enjoyed the
announcement from the Marvel panel at
the Comic Con for more updates about
Marvel & Co there are as always every
Sunday our newest episodes
[Music]